what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch a clip from the
batman uh it's a two minute clip two
minutes out of a reported four and a
half hour run time not long enough
internet is freaking out about the
length of this movie and i don't blame
them five hours is a long time to be
sitting in the theater if they could cut
it down to a reasonable epic run time of
two hours and 45 minutes
i think that would be perfectly suitable
all right guys check this out apparently
this clip as it's been featured on
youtube is uh a pre-roll
oh great yeah why not yeah and then uh
you know some people have clipped it in
but it's a clip-on that's technically on
youtube for warner brothers so yeah i
mean if it's advertising officially why
not and because of the facts of the clip
we'll probably have to like transform
some of the borders around you know to
help out without it getting blocked and
such so maybe you'll see the actual clip
before the video too and then maybe
they'll release a higher quality version
of this clip by the time this video is
out but in the meantime let's watch what
we currently have to work with
[Music]
excuse me chief here to talk to you
gil coulson is missing what
he hasn't been heard from since last
night
christ not again hey
mr wayne
[Music]
you got people looking for him jim
sent a couple guys to his house nothing
what did his wife say she hadn't heard
[Music]
damn
attention to the center is
it's like the devil's in the church
loving the suspense of this scene
yeah you can really feel the space too
get out of the car and show your hands
get out
get out show up
christ it's coulson
[Music]
i love the chaos of the crowd man
let's clear this place out now
everybody panic
bruce remains there
the batman
oh you bet your ass would experience
that holy dude that's the biggest cybex
possible if you guys haven't gone to
matt reeves twitter account yet to watch
the 4k uploads on vimeo that he himself
has put up i'm telling you it's like you
can watch a 4k re-upload on youtube it's
not going to be the same quality it just
isn't but if you want to watch like the
best-looking 4k version he has links up
there for the 4k versions i'm like oh my
god this is so beautiful
you can taste the film grain it's
glorious and to get this scene right
here which uh right away like the seven
fincher vibes are so present here i love
like the mystery allure of it all like
the tension you can just feel it the
entire time and i love how with bruce
wayne as his like he's he's in batman
mode this entire entire time he's it in
batman mode while he's surrounded by a
crowd he's listening around for any clue
he can possibly pick up on he's
remaining observant i even like like
you're kind of drawing attention to
yourself by the fact that the whole
crowd's leaving and you're staying here
but capturing like that visceral nature
of the crowd panicking and reacting to
almost every little thing just feels
like so real oh yeah i thought it was
great just a little bit right there that
was a really solid clip to get of the
kind of mood that this movie will strike
absolutely and i mean it's a testament
to that mood that i mean as we're
watching this is super grainy but even
still i got wrapped up in the tension
and the space and the air of the moment
and i love even just from the subtleties
of this scene how you can kind of
discern the direction where yeah you are
enhancing that sort of bruce is just
bruce he's observing but yeah the way
it's captured where like you know it's
on him but you can see gordon and the
other cops in the foreground discussing
things and you have all these different
vantage points of this huge church this
huge gothic room which is so perfectly
gotham but also really enhances that
tension and just like that silhouette
moment where everybody you know hits the
floor except ed nashton you know except
the riddler uh it's just i love the
tension that they're drawing i think
it's like really cool that this clip
released it starts off with him watching
the childhood i'm assuming is possibly
the son of the person whose funeral they
are attending which in some ways i'm
sure bruce wayne is seeing himself
within that little boy and then he saves
that little boy as well like that's the
whole point of why batman is batman i
feel like this is such like an
intentional clip to put out there fred's
your first official one right yeah it's
a little understated but i think when
you dig deep it makes sense although i
am a little bit uh curious though he's
right at the front of the crowd at the
uh on the balcony he's all massed up he
looks suspicious as hell pardon me
scared me and there's hard whole bunch
of cops everywhere and no one's like
who is that guy yeah that's what makes
him so evil unless of course yeah unless
he wasn't there originally then he
walked over to there as the chaos ensued
where like the car comes crashing
through you know so i'm curious about
that but the way they utilize the sound
effect i love how it doesn't cut to the
car
outside coming through crashing in you
can literally just hear the sound
elevating it's like building up that you
could hear some of the crowd outside
like the commotion
and you're just staying in locked into
the perspective of bruce wayne and
anyone in his immediate surrounding so
that way the fear is building of what's
coming through and if you've seen the
trailer you could guess what's probably
going to come through
but it still creates that level of
suspense because of the fact how they're
using the the the auditory technicality
of of the scene as well as uh locking
into perspective here i think like what
matt rage has done here with just this
one clip below and i'm like come on man
like that's why the runtime doesn't
bother me because i'd rather have a
movie that takes time that knows how to
build detention and suspense i'd rather
walk out of a film technically saying uh
yeah a couple of things could have been
cut versus i feel like this should have
been longer yeah i feel like batman of
all characters out there is one that
does merit a certain amount of
substantiality when you are making a new
iteration sure like there are a lot of
beloved batman stories that in the
comics are kind of tomes
they're thick as hell yeah and so for me
out of any superhero movie you could
have pitched as nearly three hours i
mean look at all the christopher nolan
movies like those are pretty substantial
20 minutes longer yeah absolutely and so
it does feel even though i can
understand why some people would be like
damn it's a bit long to me of all
characters batman's the most natural to
go that level with and also when you're
looking at the inspiration those are
also long movies seven zodiac those are
also two and a half plus hours so to me
that just gets me all the more excited
because of the level of tension and the
level of air you can use you don't
probably have to rush from one thing to
the next so i'm super excited for that
mood all right guys well what'd you
think about this batman clip leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that notification bell leave a
like and we will catch you all soon